the New York Times has now fully
embraced its role as the dog in the
cartoon surrounded by fire saying this
is fine
the New York Times like all
establishment organs exists for two
reasons and two reasons only one to prop
up our sclerotic ruling class and two to
demonize those of us who oppose it hence
David Leonards recent New York Times
newsletter this week in which he
declared quote strange as it may sound
the American government can function
without a healthy president
just two and a half three years ago the
times was insisting that the president
was the most important person on Earth
that Trump was mentally deranged and
that every second he remained in office
sent us hurtling that much further
toward the end of the world
now that Biden's in office and it's
obvious that while the light is on no
one's home now the times insists that
the president doesn't really matter
sure President Biden might be checked
out but see guys the government can
function without a healthy president
can it
inflation has hit record highs crime is
soaring people can't afford groceries
drugs and criminals are pouring across
the border killing so many people that
the life expectancy is declining the
economy is in free fall and we're on the
brink of World War III
where do the New York Times journals get
the idea that the government can
function without a healthy president
they don't really have that idea
they don't really think that they don't
really care about the truth at all
they just play their role and say with
the establishment wants them to say to
prop up a system we all know is failing
until one day they can't pretend anymore
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show
huge story that everyone is celebrating
about this
student who through hard work has been
accepted to a hundred and seventy
colleges and won nine million dollars in
scholarships and everybody is
celebrating this wonderful feat except
for me we'll get to that in just a
moment first though
the president is not healthy might be
the understatement of the year
the president oh he's slipped a little
bit oh yeah maybe he's lost a step or
two
Joe Biden
can't remember the last country that he
visited
country I've traveled I'm thinking once
with the last one I was in I I've been
to 89 I met with 89 heads of state so
far so I'm trying to think what was the
last where was the last place I was it's
hard to keep track
um I was I mean yeah you're right
Ireland
that's where it was
how did you know that I love a little
kid it's Ireland dummy hey don't call me
dummy I'm the president of the United
States you got to respect your elders
you forget iron
oh yeah you're right it was Ireland okay
but Joe Biden he travels a lot
I I understand it I hit the road
sometimes I forget was I last in
Wisconsin or Michigan
now on Wisconsin and Michigan are a
little more similar than say Ireland and
Japan or something like that but okay
all right he he just sort of forgot
someone reminded him now
later on in his remarks he seemed to
forget something that's that tells us a
little bit more about who the man is he
forgot how many grandchildren he has
I have six grandchildren and I'm crazy
about them and I speak to them every
single day not a joke matter of fact I
just got finished going through the
calls and uh only one of them answered
the phone uh but at least I got to leave
a message and their my oldest
granddaughter is named after one of my
daughters who I lost in an accident a
long time ago and her name is Naomi so
he says I got six grandchildren and I
call them every single day seriously
that's no joke Jack except he doesn't he
has seven grandchildren and he refuses
to acknowledge his grandchild by Hunter
this four-year-old girl who I don't
think he forgot I think he just refuses
to acknowledge her and I I keep bringing
this up because it's a really nasty
thing to do imagine that you're this
little girl and your grandpa is the
president of the United States and your
your father is a degenerate but at least
your grandpa is supposed to be this
upstanding guy is the president United
States and he refuses to acknowledge
Your Existence that would probably make
you feel pretty low about yourself even
if you don't think that when you're four
and by the age of four you're starting
to be aware of things but certainly by
the age of 14 certainly by the age of 40
you realize oh yeah my grandfather the
president was so ashamed of me that he
wouldn't acknowledge my existence that's
a nasty nasty thing to do and that's not
just forgetting that's Joe Biden
typically not caring about the truth
and ignoring the truth and pursuing
merely what is convenient for him and so
it tells you something about his
presidency and I'm not just picking on
Joe Biden it tells you something about
the state of our ruling class if a man
will not acknowledge the truth
about even his own family people that
he's supposed to love
this the smallest political Community
the most fundamental political building
block if he won't acknowledge the truth
about that
how is he going to acknowledge the truth
about everything else
how can you expect him to tell the truth
about the rest of politics
and if the president of the United
States
refuses to acknowledge the truth if he's
just going to live in a fantasy world of
his own where he makes up his his
academic record and he makes up his
Corn Pop stories and his father's
stories and his grandchildren's stories
and makes up all sorts of events for 50
years now in politics
how are we going to live in a system
that flourishes
if our political leaders refuse to
tether themselves to reality how are we
supposed to get along according to
reality when you when you live according
to lives when you live according to
Fantasy you're not going to have a
flourishing Society that's something
we've got to talk about when you want to
talk to your friends you got to check
out
pure talk right now go to peartalk.com
use promo code Knowles we all know about
the big wireless cell companies out
there they lock you into these
horrendous contracts if you try to get
out of them early they tack on
outrageous charges that is why I'm so
pleased to use Pure Talk Wireless where
there are no hidden fees no contracts no
hassle pure talks U.S customer service
team made it incredibly easy to sign up
you can keep your old phone number if
you want Pure Talk has a range of
affordable cell phone plans to choose
from you can find the perfect option for
your needs such as unlimited talk text
and plenty of data for just thirty
dollars a month their 5G service is fast
consistent doesn't drop your calls you
get the same coverage when I say the
same I don't mean similar I mean the
same coverage that you are used to at
half the rate you're currently paying
puretalk saves the average family over
nine hundred dollars per year not only
will you save more money you will also
get the satisfaction of knowing you're
supporting a great American company the
CEO and chairman of pure talk is a US
military vet with when you become a Pure
Talk customer you're given the option to
support America's Warrior partnership
which works to prevent veteran suicide
go to puretalk.com enter promo code
Knowles save 50 off your first month
five zero percent that is puretalk.com
promo code knows Pure Talk is simply
smarter Wireless
speaking of political orders falling
apart this is the most disturbing story
I've heard all week
out of the Netherlands
officials in the Netherlands have
approved assisted suicide for people
ages 1 to 12.
babies to pre-teens can now kill
themselves
legally and doctors can help them do it
they will permit the doctors to
euthanize children deemed to have
conditions which will lead to hopeless
and unbearable suffering
now the way that the Dutch officials are
describing it they say oh this is for a
very extreme cases people who are days
away from certain death and they're in
such intense pain that we're just going
to put them out of their misery now this
is not how euthanasia how assisted
suicide actually works in practice you
remember shortly after the Netherlands
approved assisted suicide some years ago
people warned this isn't going to be
only used in extreme cases this is going
to be used to put down people who the
the state deems Unworthy of life even
people who don't want to die and then
there is a very famous case of a woman
who did have dementia and so I guess she
had forgotten that she had authorized
this
assisted suicide and when the doc came
to poison her she she said no and the
doc said too bad I'm killing you anyway
and she said no no no and she fought
back she tried to push him away and then
her family held her down while the
doctor killed this woman
that's what it looks like and what it
looks like is incentivizing people who
are a little bit depressed who are a
little bit anxious who fear that they're
a burden to their families
incentivizes people to kill themselves
and now they're doing it for little kids
and everyone looks at this and they say
this is horrible this is shocking how
did this happen
this was always going to happen
it's the same people who look at
transiting the kids and they say oh my
gosh this is shocking how did this
happen this was always going to happen
the minute you accept the logic of
assisted suicide of euthanasia
euthanasia which is called it's it's a
term that means good death but it's not
a good death it's the worst death of all
it's the death that it totally expresses
despair
the moment that we accepted that logic
that the perfect expression of Despair
is a good death
and it was always going to
end up with the kids the moment that we
accepted the idea that you had some sort
of right to kill yourself that was
always going to go down to the kids just
as when we accepted the idea that a man
can secretly be a woman well then that
was always going to affect the kids
because if it's true if the transgender
anthropology is true then of course we
have to extend the transit procedures to
little kids it would be cruel not to If
there really it's really a girl trapped
in a boy's body then of course we've got
to put him on cross-sex hormones
certainly before puberty we've got to
make some interventions because
otherwise it'll be harder for him to
transition and express his true self
but it isn't true
and in the case of suicide you don't
have a right to kill yourself
there is no way to make a coherent
argument for the right so-called
to kill yourself
so it's just a pure imposition of will
you say well I want to do it
and by the way we've got all these
people that I deem useless and valueless
so let's just get rid of them you know
they're just a drain on society and then
we get horrified when we see The Logical
consequences of that play out I have to
give a little bit of credit to will
Thomas you know the guy who goes by Leah
he's the swimmer who beat all the girls
on the Penn swim team will Thomas was
just on some sort of podcast
and he explained how unreasonable it is
for conservatives to buy into parts of
transgenderism but then oppose men in
women's sports
they're like oh we respect Leah as a
woman as a trans woman or whatever we
respect our identity we just don't think
it's fair you can't really have that
that sort of half support where you're
like oh I respect you as a woman here
but not here they're using the guys of
feminism to sort of push transphobic
beliefs and I think a lot of people in
that camp sort of carry an implicit bias
against trans people but don't one I
guess fully manifest or speak that out
and so they try to just play it off as
this sort of half support they think
about how twisted feminism quote unquote
feminism has become their arguments you
know in order to exclude anybody in the
trans category you have to reduce women
to reproductive capacity which is in my
opinion extremely anti-feminist I don't
want to put those women down either and
I know you don't want don't want to
either because I see pain I see pain and
the pain is coming from somewhere it's
not you though it's the patriarchy and
how can we get people to see that
no I think it's you I think it's coming
from you and it's coming from people who
are invading their bathrooms and their
locker rooms and taking their trophies
and their scholarships that's where it's
coming from will is right this host of
the show is completely incoherent but
will Thomas is totally right
when he says it just doesn't make sense
you're gonna you're going to respect me
as a woman in certain parts of society
but not in others you're going to go
halfway you're going to tell me that you
know that I'm a woman but you're going
to behave as though you know that I'm
not a woman doesn't make sense
doesn't make sense
will Thomas totally right
not only is he a great swimmer at least
when he's racing women but he's more
logical than just about anybody in the
transgender
movement
either transgenderism has to be
established in our law and in our
culture as activists are trying to do
right now they've been trying to do this
since 2020 so it's relatively recent but
in the Bostock decision from the Supreme
Court in Harris Funeral Homes decision
from the Supreme Court
the court has said we are going to
redefine legal protections on the basis
of sex and we're going to now say that
there are protections on the basis of
gender identity which ironically
undermines protections on the basis of
sex
if you have legal protections on the
basis of sex that says girls get their
own swim teams
and then you redefine that to say
actually people who identify as girls
get their own swim teams then what
you've said is girls do not have their
own swim teams because will Thomas is
going to compete against you and take
your trophies
okay that's what our law has
increasingly been saying
we either need to follow that to its
full conclusion
or
for the good of society and especially
for the good of the poor people have
fallen prey to this confusion
transgenderism must be eradicated from
public life entirely the entire ideology
from top to bottom
so those are the two options
will will Thomas and I are in agreement
on this subject if you disagree I don't
know you're disagreeing with the most
prominent spokesman of the transgender
movement and knuckle dragging
conservatives such as I
speaking of being divorced from the
truth Dylan Mulvaney it wouldn't be a
day that ends in y if Dylan Mulvaney
were not thrusting himself into the
headlines Dylan Mulvaney has accelerated
his activism and he now says
that we ought to arrest people who refer
to him as a man
articles written about me using he
pronouns and calling me a man over and
over again and I I feel like that should
be illegal I I don't know that's that's
just bad journalism I feel that should
be illegal don't you we should arrest
people who don't think that I'm a
beautiful stunning woman
I'm just a picture of Grace and
femininity I Dylan Mulvaney we should
arrest those people
we went from
just leave us alone how does this affect
you what's your problem why are you so
obsessed with us to call me a beautiful
lady or you're going to prison
in
like six months
that was pretty fast wasn't it
Dylan Mulvaney has only been pretending
to be a woman for slightly over one year
he's on his 368th day or something like
that of pretending to be a woman and we
went from tihihi isn't this so silly I'm
a lady
how does this affect you too you're
going to the gulag if if you don't call
me she actually sir it's ma'am it's it's
that video of the giant guy in the
bodega that guy is more Peaceable and
amiable than Dylan Mulvaney
Dylan Mulvaney doesn't yell and scream
but the threat is far more serious
this is what
they want why
why are they so insistent
because public lies
require ever more Force to prop them up
if you're telling the truth and you're
orienting your Society according to the
truth you don't need nearly as much
force because the truths on which you
base your Society are clear to people
people can perceive them they can deduce
them using their reason they can Intuit
them using their moral conscience
if however you're grounding your Society
on absurdities then those absurdities
are not clear to people
in fact it's it's quite clear that
they're false and so to establish them
in society you need Force to tell people
don't believe your eyes don't use your
faculties of Reason deny your moral
conscience
shut up or we're throwing you in the
gulag
that's why
that's why at times in our Nations and
civilizations history when Society has
been more normal and in line with
reality the government has had a lighter
touch
the government can afford a lighter
touch but as Society becomes more absurd
the government has to become more
tyrannical the government has to become
totalitarian
because any little crack in the artifice
that has been built up can threaten the
whole system so if you're living
according to Communism say which is
based on false ideas about human nature
and reality then you can't allow
you can't allow a representative of the
people to speak up in Congress or the
parliament certainly not but you can't
even allow a novelist to question it you
can't even allow Pro families to
question it around the dinner table you
certainly can't allow TV shows to
question these sorts of things because
any little crack
will be persuasive to people
because people
can know something about the truth they
can recognize the truth
Sometimes using their reason using their
moral conscience
don't don't think this is Dylan Mulvaney
Jumping the Shark he's not this is the
inevitable consequence of establishing a
lie so absurdist transgenderism in our
law and culture speaking of
irrationality North Carolina man
was critically injured he almost died
when his neighbor
allegedly started shooting him and his
poor little girl and some other children
why did the Neighbors start shooting the
children and then the father why did he
try to murder the little kids because
their ball rolled into his yard
these little children were playing with
a ball and the ball rolled into his yard
so he got a gun and tried to murder the
children why did he do it well he yelled
I don't even like white people
his name is Robert Lewis Singletary he's
24 years old turned himself into
authorities after he was on the lamb for
a couple of days and realized he was
going to get caught so he goes he turns
himself in he fired at this poor little
girl and her parents white and Ashley
Hildebrand
after after the ball rolled onto the
property said you white I don't even
like white people I'm going to shoot
your AWS and then according to the
father he fires three shots he hasn't
hit anybody yet so I turn around and
look my daughter's right in front of me
I look and see he's pointing straight at
my daughter so this father just jumps
and he gets shot and was critically
injured the daughter caught shrapnel in
her cheek but luckily
luckily they they seem to have lived
you almost certainly haven't heard about
the story anywhere maybe on some
conservative Channel but this sort of
thing is suppressed obviously goes
without saying if the if the races were
reversed then this would be a national
news story the president would give a
speech about it there would be a
national conversation going on there
might be riots but in this case it's not
we just sort of ignore it we ignore the
fact that he shot these people because
they're white
this is
the real American Constitution lowercase
C Constitution we have an uppercase C
Constitution that's written on parchment
and that uppercase C constitution
written on parchment
is related to other founding documents
The Federalist Papers the Declaration of
Independence
and so we have this view of how American
society Works based on Schoolhouse Rock
You know I'm a billup on Capitol Hill
but that's not the real Constitution
according to the real Constitution
there are favored groups and disfavored
groups
and if you're a member of a favored
group you will be treated differently by
the law and by the culture and if you're
a member of a disfavored group
and that's what we're seeing playing out
now and some of those are sometimes in
flux women for instance are more favored
than men
but they are less favored than men who
think that they're women and so so if
women women can claim discrimination by
men and the law will look favorably upon
them but women can't claim
discrimination by so-called trans women
the men who think that they're women the
law will look more favorably on the
transgenderist people
obviously according to the law into the
culture white people are pretty much the
only group that you can discriminate
against and insult and non-white people
can do no wrong they're the greatest
people on Earth every problem is because
of whiteness every solution will be by
turning away from whiteness the original
sin of our civilization these are ideas
that are not only floating around the
culture but are articulated explicitly
by the people who wield power in the
culture and so
a a presidential candidate as we look
ahead to 2024 a presidential candidate
who
is successful
is going to have to speak to the real
lowercase C Constitution not just on
this issue of you know black people good
white people bad that our popular
culture puts out
oh yes this guy shot a little tried to
shoot a little girl and I guess
ultimately did because of the shrapnel
energy because she's white
oh yeah okay never mind move along with
lung but not just that it's the whole
issue of how does our society really
work put aside the transgender issues
and the race issues and all those other
issues how does our society really work
who wields the power how do we bring
those powerful forces back into line how
do we reign in the media the New York
Times the state paper
from from
basically just pushing State propaganda
how do we fix that how do we how do we
tweak the education system all the rest
of it a real successful presidential
candidate I don't want to hear
platitudes about the Fourth of July and
the Declaration of Independence I want
people to address the actual
Constitution According to which the
unwritten Constitution According to
which society operates today because we
are in National decline I hope we're not
headed for National death we might be
you are headed for death at some point
that's why you got to check out epic
will right now go to epicwill.com
Knowles there are certain things in life
that you do to protect your family you
get life insurance you save for a rainy
day fund you write a will epic will is
not for people who are already wealthy
with a massive estate those people need
an attorney epic will is for people who
are okay that's cool oh that's great you
know well that's all right it's epic
well how are you well what's up what's
up hey Michael so tomorrow's my birthday
yes I was just about to wish you a happy
birthday were you actually I was I'm
actually accepting cash
well uh take five dollars I've got um I
actually oddly enough I do have money
um can you break a can you break a
hundred I don't think there's a reason
to break it you just take it right away
just take cash for my birthday that
sounds fabulous so wow you're turning
26. 26 again again yeah and so I just
wanted to see
um guys for epic well there are certain
things in life that you do to protect
your family you get life insurance you
save for a rainy day fund and you write
a will epical isn't for people who are
already wealthy with a massive estate
those people need an attorney epic goals
for people who are building their estate
it's for people who are just getting
started Epico provides a simple and
secure platform to create a legally
binding will in just minutes their user
friendly interface allows you to easily
customize your will and ensure that your
assets are distributed according to your
wishes unlike those traditional law
firms that charge High fees for will
drafting Epic Wheel services are
affordable and they're transparent with
no hitting costs or surprises all you
need to do is fill out their
step-by-step form and they'll help you
create your last will and testament
living will health care and financial
power of attorney in as little as five
minutes and for just
119 dollars having a look and ensure
that your wishes are carried out after
you pass away and they also provide you
peace of mind for both you and your
loved ones so go to epicworld.com
Knowles Canada wlas to save 10 on Epic
Will's complete will package that's
epicwell.com Knowles be sure to leave me
some money for I was I was wondering as
as The Godfather to a certain uh Candace
child
how much do I get in the will
I have to go hmm I do have to go
um I will break that 100 later great
okay wonderful accepting cash for my
birthday or if you can leave it in your
will because it's my birthday cro not
really today and I'm gonna get the
question mark on those later
happy birthday thank you
if you watched Netflix's hit show making
a murderer you are going to love daily
wire Plus's new exclusive 10 part series
with Candace convicting a murderer
coming this summer making a murderer was
a gripping tale of Stephen Avery a man
wrongly convicted of sexual assault in
1985 and then just two years after his
released accused of a gruesome murder
the series suggested that Avery was
innocent and set up by the Manta towak
did I pronounce that correctly County
Sheriff's Department it made his
conviction feel like a significant
miscarriage of American justice as
millions of people rallied behind Avery
passionately claiming that the truth
will come out but what if the truth is
even more shocking than anyone expected
what if there's more to the story than
what we were shown as you know Candace
is a fierce advocate for the truth and
she is diving headfirst into the
notorious Steven Avery case in her new
series convicting a murderer
she's disclosing the shocking parts of
Avery's story that were omitted in the
Netflix series is there an innocent man
behind bars or did the Real miscarriage
of Justice happen from when Hollywood
decided to get involved in the first
case
find out this summer in our new
explosive 10-part series convicting a
murderer exclusively on daily wire plus
but don't wait until then to sign up
right now you can get 35 off your
membership with code truth this offer
will not be available for long so become
a member today and be here when the
truth finally comes out daily wire.com
subscribe
speaking of racial politics lost in the
story about Tucker Carlson being fired
by Fox
was a happier story Don Lemon being
fired by CNN Don Lemon gets fired
apparently his agent told him CNN didn't
even have the courtesy to sit down with
him and give him the information face to
face he says I was informed this morning
by my age and that I've been terminated
by CNN I'm stunned after 17 years at CNN
I would have thought that someone in
management would have had the decency to
tell me directly
I don't really care that much about the
Don Lemon story
what's interesting about it is to think
of Don Lemon as the anti-tucker
it happened at the same time
both prominent cable news heads who lost
their their jobs
but they're the opposite in many ways
Tucker started out as a magazine
journalist very good writer
and something of an establishment type
of conservative
he talks about this frequently he he
pushed propaganda that today he never
would have pushed he was just sucked in
by it
and then over time
Tucker became more and more disenchanted
with the establishment and so his show
on Fox
was quite different from the other shows
no knock on the other guys I still have
a number of friends over at Fox News
but Tucker was different
Tucker was not following the script that
a lot of
people in politics follow
Don Lemon on the other hand started out
cutting Against the Grain at CNN
Don Lemon started out questioning the
leftist narrative he would sometimes
agree with Bill O'Reilly Don Lemon would
sometimes criticize the BLM movement
and then the more and more he was at CNN
Don Lemon
fell more and more into the liberal
establishment line
and then they both wind up in the same
place they both get canned
what would you rather be
I think a lot of people just toe the
line in order to keep their job or out
of fear that there will be some kind of
reprisal but look in the in the long run
we're all dead okay so what what would
you rather do would you rather pursue
the truth and maybe you get canned for
it down the line maybe if the Vanity
Fair story is Right Tucker got fired
because he told people to go pray to God
or would you like to
just go along to get along and say all
manner of things that you probably know
aren't true and then you wind up in the
same place
and it's the same story in form just
at the end
totally radically different okay there's
a story that everybody is celebrating
so sweet so wonderful how proud we all
are it's of a student who has won nine
million dollars in scholarships after
now having been accepted to 170 colleges
here's how the news covered this a
little earlier about about 45 colleges
ago as he was already winning a lot of
money in scholarships and being accepted
to a lot of schools
Dennis Florence has gone into
125 colleges and universities he's also
earned millions in scholarships that's
for how he did it well the teen is very
humble and credits hard work and those
around him
Theo College what school is this
hillbrook college
who is been devoted to trying to get my
school work done and get good grades
always of course like the average child
at just 16 Dennis Barnes is anything but
the average child he's just a few weeks
away from graduating from International
High School and he's got a big decision
to make what college will he attend I
have Loyola Marymount University
well he's got at least 125 to choose
from it's not normal I know it's not of
course
it's not normal this is not everyone is
so happy about this story
I don't like this story
I like that the kid did well in school
and got good grades and he's going to go
to a college that he wants to go to
this is not normal and this is not
humble
and this is not right
whoever encouraged this kid to do this
did not do him any favors
why would you apply to 170 schools
you can only go to one school
you can only accept one scholarship or
number of scholarships from the same
school so what's the point of this
the point of this is just to brag and to
get a headline and to get a news story
but what's the consequence of this the
consequence of this is that
lots of other students 169 other
students are not going to get into
schools because this guy wants to be
able to brag about how many schools he
got into
what is he bragging about let's I don't
know what colleges he got into let's say
he's a math genius and he got into MIT
he got into MIT wow okay is there a news
story for a kid got into MIT no because
a lot of kids get into MIT every year
it's very hard in school to get into but
a lot of kids do it there aren't these
news stories
because most of these kids don't also
get into 170 other schools even though
they could if you get into MIT for math
you can get into any other school in the
country for math
almost without exception
I'm sure you could get 20 million
dollars in scholarships offered
because at the very top schools the
scholarships are not merit-based they're
need based so if you don't come from a
lot of money you'll get those and then
at the lower schools you'll be offering
a ton of Merit Scholarships if you're
debating between
polucoville State and MIT for math you
know that the smaller school is going to
offer you some money based on Merit
because you got into the bigger School
this is all about the self it and it's I
don't I'm not really not knocking the
kid for it because in the News segment
you can tell his parents are encouraging
him to do this his teachers and his
guidance counselors are encouraging him
to do this just wrong in the old days
you used to apply to a few schools that
you wanted to go to
and then when you got into your school
that you wanted to go to you withdrew
your other applications and you say okay
now now these other people how this
wonderful feeling that I just felt of
being accepted to the school I want to
go to now that I know that I'm going to
go to that school
I'm going to allow other people to have
that nice feeling of being accepted to
the school that they want to go to but
that's not how we look at it now
we don't we don't even look at College
as a way to become educated we just look
at it as a credential for a resume today
getting into college is is
harder and more important than
graduating college
it's
still difficult to get into a lot of
colleges in the country
but once you're in it's almost
impossible to flunk out it's pretty easy
to graduate
so what this says is it's just a it's a
way of establishing some kind of
credential that you're on the right
track doesn't really matter what you
learn the purpose of an education is to
get outside of yourself in your own base
desires and your own self-obsession and
to see
the truth
and to see a bigger world and and to
cultivate yourself to become immersed in
culture and the grand story of your
whole civilization and to realize that
you're just playing one little role here
in a much bigger story in a much bigger
picture and the way it's not just this
kid it's not just this news network it's
not just
it's even it's the way that the schools
now cultivate students
they put all the focus on the self what
do you want to study what do you think
maybe you can make your own major
I mean you you you I remember you this
is true even 10 years ago now I guess 15
years ago when I was a freshman in
college when we sit down and
for the first week of orientation all
we're told is you're the future you are
the Future Leaders of America you're the
greatest people in the whole wide world
that's that's backwards and if that's
the way you're educated
you're not going to be educated very
well looking around our country that
appears to be what's going on finally
finally
we have arrived at my favorite time of
the week when I get to hear from you in
the mailmag my favorite comment
yesterday is from Aaron voton who says
always know it's going to be a good show
when the YouTube warning about the New
World Order shows up very very true
there's no new world order here what are
you talking about here's how we're going
to prove that there's no new world order
here by uh censoring you every time you
even suggest that there is one
this mailbag is sponsored by pure talk
at puretalk.com select to plan enter
code Knowles Canada wl-e-sd at 50 off
your first month
take it away
hey Michael so I've got a serious
question for you
why do you and other daily wire host
play clips from The View
does anybody even watch that show
and if they do why but if they don't why
do you play their clips
also it always makes me laugh when you
say people got so open-minded that their
brain fell out so thanks for that giggle
hope you are having a great day
wonderful question and I have the same
question myself I looked around I said
wait a second why
are we conservatives
covering the view because I had done it
and I would see it pop up in news
articles but then I'd say hold on does
it matter
who are we the only people who watch the
video I can't imagine anybody would
choose to listen to Joy Behar
and then I looked the view is the
highest rated show in daytime TV
there are a lot of people who watch The
View
it's wrong it's terrible
it makes me weep for my country but it
actually is a pretty Big Show and I
think sometimes
if you're listening to this show you are
pretty plugged into politics you're
paying pretty close attention to matters
of politics and culture and philosophy
more so than the average person down the
street
and so it's easy for us to get trapped
in our own bubble
and and then we're surprised when
politics turns out in ways that we think
are unreasonable
that's why I think to get a finger on
the pulse of a certain very large
segment of America
we have to subject ourselves to Whoopi
Goldberg
next question
hello Nostradamus this is Sheila I
wanted to get your thoughts on something
I currently hold the job in which all
other jobs in our society exist to
support I'm a domestic engineer and a
homeschooling mom as well as a business
owner I wanted to have uh your thoughts
on these School vouchers so a lot of us
in the homeschooling Community are
really against these School vouchers we
think they might be a great thing for
public school systems but as far as for
even private schools or especially
homeschooling we really think this is a
trojan horse we really think this is a
way that the government is going to sink
their claws into our curriculum into
what we're teaching into our homes into
the lives of our children if we're
seeing some of this transgender stuff
happening in the public schools in the
government-run schools then why wouldn't
they just do the same in our homes and
regulating homes as soon as we take
their money we are in their debt we are
have to adhere to their policies their
rules their regulations so just want to
get your thoughts on this in the words
of General Akbar from Star Wars It's a
trap thanks
it's a risk there's no question it's a
risk it's a risk that I would be willing
to take now because
the risk is
not that the government will be able to
force you to change your home school
curricula
but that it will just incentivize you to
because if you're a homeschool parent
you're going to homeschool your kids no
matter what okay and the government's
not going to have that much to say about
it
[Music]
but the fear is you might
start to like that money
and then you might be willing to
compromise on your curricula
to keep the money coming in and so
that's a risk
but then the flip side is with the
school vouchers for not only certain
charter schools and parochial schools
but but for homeschooling
you are really damaging the power grip
of the teachers union
and you were weakening the Monopoly of
this
this teacher Union Democrat bureaucrat
Alliance
that totally owns public education in
America which means they own education
in America period and so it's a little
bit of a balance and the question is are
you willing to take that risk of maybe
creating a tough incentive for
homeschool parents in order to deal a
real strong punch to the control of the
teachers union I would be willing to
take that risk yes I think it's worked
out pretty well for the charter schools
and the parochial schools I think that
the American people are very much on our
side with
School vouchers and homeschooling right
now I think covid really helped that out
so I think the political conditions
today are such that I would be willing
to take that risk if it were a different
time in history maybe not but but it's
it's politics is like Blackjack
in that if you always play by the same
rules all the time and you never change
your strategy ultimately you're going to
lose
but if you know when to split if you
know when to double down if you know
when to
employ certain tactics then you've got a
very good chance of winning okay next
question hey Michael long time listener
really big fan I have a question
concerning my boyfriend we've been
dating now for about two and a half
years and early on in our relationship
we really prioritized health and fitness
just getting in the gym having a healthy
lifestyle
recently uh I'd say about the last six
months he's really been slacking and he
has put on weight and is unhealthy I
just don't know what I should do I don't
know if I should talk to him about
getting back in the gym and his weight
and his health or if I should just let
him be let him do his own thing so
really any advice that you could give me
would be really appreciated thank you
it's a delicate issue but I think you're
well within your rights to be concerned
you might raise the question
from a sincere care for
your boyfriend's emotional mental
spiritual health
it might be more than just he really
likes that Fried Chicken that his
grandma makes
and he might be a little bit depressed
he might be overworked he might be
stressed so you might say hey
Johnny
what's going on are you are you doing
all right
can't help but look I love you you could
be 300 pounds I would still love you but
I've noticed you know you seem you seem
to be a little bit different you see
what's going on how can I help
that would be one way to do it
another way to help would be to get
married and then you're cooking for him
and then you can just decide what he
eats and that's that's been really great
because sweet little Elisa Cooks
99.7 of the food in our home and the
other point three percent is when I just
drive by fast food and you know sneak a
Arby's double beef and cheddar or
something like that but
because sweet little Alisa Cooks
magnificent food in a rather healthy way
even when I glut myself I
usually don't get too fat so that would
be a long-term way of exerting your
influence here is you know you get
married and then you're making all the
food but but I would just I wouldn't
frame the issue from the standpoint of
hey you used to be really hot and I used
to find you hot now I think you're fat
and ugly so fix this or I'm going to
leave you I would just frame it from the
position of hey I care about you I love
you I I love you in that I will your
good for your own sake and
a physical changes can express
deeper issues and you seem like you're
having a rough go of it so what is it
talk to me talk to me baby okay next
question
hey Michael it's Sophia your number two
fan girl after Julia your number one fan
girl I need some marital advice I'm
getting married to the best man I've
ever known in less than a month and I've
never been happier in my life
I can't wait to be his wife take care of
the home and have oodles and oodles and
babies God's willing my question
concerns our differences in time
management skills I'm a really punctual
person I like being on time often early
and I'm very good at managing my time
but my fiance is not and he would be the
first to admit it he gets distracted
he's got a bit of ADD and it it's hard
for him to manage his time
how would you manage this how would you
suggest that I manage this issue thanks
I love your show
thank you so much lovely question I'm
even going to put aside for a moment
that you you referred to this man as the
most wonderful finest man you've ever
known right after you said you're my
number two fangirl I guess that's why
you're not my number one you know
because I don't rank number one for you
oh that's okay that's good I'm glad that
you love your fiancee so much but you've
got this problem and it's a problem that
resonates for me because I am also
habitually late
I'm not
egregiously late but I am habitually
fashionable or fashionably or slightly
more than fashionably light that's the
way it is Annalisa is extremely punctual
and she's made me more punctual Than I
Used to Be
but we still have this issue and so
being fashionably light is a fine thing
that can sometimes be actually
appropriate if you're invited to a
dinner party you say show up at five
o'clock and then you get there you know
4 59 and a half knock knock that would
be inappropriate you really do want to
show up at 410
ish you know maybe 4 15 even I push it a
little bit uh but
let's pull this out a little bit from
just the this future marital spat over
time management and
get to all marital disagreements
topic seems to be in the news these days
let's say
that you and your spouse
have a conflict
and the conflict is over
should we show up on time to a dinner or
half an hour late
the way most people think of marital
conflicts
should you put away your clothing or
should you leave it strewn about the
house this is another fault of mine I
leave my clothing strewn everywhere
should you
I don't know do the dishes or not do the
dishes should you pay your bills should
you not pay bills so whatever the spat
is over the way people today view
marital conflicts and conflicts broadly
is this a battle between two opposing
Wills I want to do this and you want to
do this and I'm going to force my will
on you or you're going to force your
will on me and I you don't respect me
enough and right that's the way that we
we all in our culture are
inclined to think about these things
what would be healthier and more helpful
probably is to think about these as a
question of what is good or bad what is
right or wrong what is true or false so
instead of it just becoming a battle of
wills it becomes a question for the
intellect
is it
right to be invited over to someone's
house and show up half an hour late no
that's rude that's impolite that's
unjust that's not good to do
it's imprudent because if you keep doing
that and people are going to stop
inviting you over because you keep
screwing up their dinner parties and so
you can have you can discuss that and
it's no longer about me getting my way
or you getting your way it's about what
is right okay here's what's right and
sometimes Maybe
I'm more inclined to do the right thing
and you have a harder time with it
sometimes maybe you're more inclined to
do the right thing and I have a harder
time with it
but if we focus on that
outside of us and then we're both
pursuing that thing together
as one flesh two individuals that come
together and a man and a woman
complementary make one flesh it's going
to be
much more conducive to flourishing
because it's no longer going to be I
hate that you're making me do this it's
going to be rather I hate that I don't
have the habit of virtue to be inclined
to do the thing that is right all the
time this is this is why when people say
you've got to put God at the center of
your marriage it's not just some soapy
kind of happy Sacrament thing to say
it's a really important
it's a really important part of your
whole life but but especially in a
marriage
because you've got to have your focus be
on the truth
that's how you're going to get along and
grow together and flourish
otherwise if your focus is just on your
yourself and your own subjective desires
and your own disordered will and your
own imposition of of what what you
desire
then you're going to have conflict
just the way it goes
the rest of the show continues now you
do not want to miss it become a member
and use code Knowles Canada wlas at
check out for two months free on all
annual plans this is fake headline
Friday I need your help
to pick the fake headline among the real
ones we'll see over there
[Music]